you know one of the things that we've
discussed also is if you take a look at
all the calendar applications out there
um you're pretty much looking at a
situation of brand parity you pull off
the logos and you're talking about very
similar feature functions yeah
um you know everybody's worried about
their own platform and their own
audience and so
you know for us it's an opportunity to
say okay well you know scheduling has
kind of bled a little bit into the
calendar space and if we're gonna go
there what are the differentiation
points right the world doesn't need
another calendar
it could use a tool to Aggregate and it
could use it could use an intelligent
calendar that's a little bit more
evolved but
um you know how do we make a difference
how do we change the product because it
hasn't changed in thousands of years
yeah yeah well analytics I think is the
near-term thing that everyone could use
and it's not that hard to do but no one
has done it that's right
um so I think zodney really opened my
eyes on that part of analytics of email
because again you're in the email every
single day and you're on top of it and
you're responsive and you think you know
but until you see those analytics and
you say oh my God I didn't realize that
yeah
these five people are the you know 80 of
my time of who I'm sending email to I
think if you did the same thing to a
calendar
to know where you're spending your time
yeah that would be huge absolutely and
if there are you know I'm not that into
this stuff but like uh uh who is it
Franklin is the calendar Franklin
planner Franklin Planner yeah they have
some interesting kinds of uh
ways of
analyzing what you do and thinking about
what you do and there's another
what is this metrics thing about uh
there's some metrics thing about getting
stuff done
what it is but anyway it's an entirely
separate thing but if you took those
Concepts and applied those to analyzing
your calendar
you know eye-opening kinds of things I
want to shift gears for one second and
you know again it's a conversation we've
had and I don't want to
um I don't want to let you think for a
second that we're basing our model at
all on Advertising but there's something
very unique happening on the calendar
which is that when we kind of looked
look at
ad revenues advertising contextualize
advertising one of the things that's
most interesting uh when we look at the
Spectrum of say a plan cast on one end
the Declaration of intent and Foursquare
on the other well Foursquare is I'm here
now and it's just too late there's
nothing you can really do on calendar
once you've put something into the
calendar you've declared your intent to
be somewhere in the future that's the
greatest single opportunity for anyone
to talk to you you've got the greatest
disposable income and you're about to
move down the funnel to Here and Now
right and so from the perspective
strictly of advertising contextual
advertising uh marketing you've got a
goal of mine there right if you're able
to open and unleash that data set you're
really providing something to marketers
which is unique I think right it's this
um I'm going to be there in the future
I'm going so if you take a look at
Travel for a second and just kind of a
process on travel I get permission from
Mark I'm going to go travel the next
thing I do is I slot it off my calendar
I block off some time I may then push it
out to my social network to let people
know that I'm going to be in a
particular City at a particular time but
then the funnel begins right I need
airline I need Hotel I need a car I need
a whole bunch of decisions that I'm
making and every step along the way I'm
spending some money the only people that
really have visibility into that entire
flow are the guys who are holding the
calendar because that's the insertion
point yeah any thoughts there yeah
TripIt tries to do that uh with travel
so that it has your Airline reservation
your rental car your hotel your
everything all in one spot
but for me I'm a calendar guy so I would
rather go to my calendar and see there's
my rental car reservation number there's
my hotel reservation and there's my
flight because I want to be on my phone
right and just click on the calendar and
see everything at all everything there I
don't want to have to go to email and
search for the vendor for the particular
vendor and find out okay which because
if I do a search on Hertz I've got 30 of
them right and I gotta figure out which
one is it that's that one or you know
that kind of stuff so TripIt tries to
aggregate that data for trips in a
separate application I don't want to go
to a separate application I'd rather
have it in a calendar so you know
there's a way to do that awesome
but there are some of these things that
really are the responsibility of Outlook
or Google Calendar or a Yahoo calendar
right they're not
do you think that you can
overlay these features or somehow add
these prompts or
is it they're doing it provided that
weakness and provided that we can build
the right user base of course
um I think we can I think that you know
again a lot of these prompts and these
notifications and these suggestive
components are an amalgamation of
different data sources
so I think we're in a good position to
be able to do that even as you look at
tongle now it's an adjunct to a core
calendar right it's a no point is it a
replacement to any of the you know
primary calendaring systems out there
and so when we talk about all these
things again at a very high level I
think they're modules they're bolt-ons
to what we know as kind of core calendar
right you know anyone here has the
intention
um
or is presumptive enough to believe that
we're going to take on a Google Calendar
or an IBM nodes or an iCal or what have
you yeah right user bases are installed
of all the things and hence we can
enhance the experience of all the things
we've talked about the thing that
excites me the most is analytics on how
I've spent my time and then maybe goal
setting about how I want to spend my
time in the future and the calendar sort
of sets these goals about hey you said
you wanted to spend 20 of your time on
this so slot it in there and you know
then or maybe it kind of graphs out how
you'd like to spend your time and maybe
it's color coded or something I don't
know right and then you start
inputting specific meetings and
schedules and and then you see if you're
meeting your goal or not to me the the
little hanging fruits are analytics of
your past but also giving you tools for
for your future but not just what you
talked about for example I'm going to be
meeting with Jonathan I never met him in
the past and I so I don't know him but
my calendar knows I'm going to be
meeting all these people so all of a
sudden I can start looking at their
Twitter feed and I can start looking
about their LinkedIn profile and all
this stuff that's publicly available
Jonathan so I get to know him before I
actually meet him so when I'm talking to
him I can know that he I don't know he
walked his dog yesterday and whatever
happened and I can start a conversation
with him he's gonna go ah you actually
know me a bit more and so there's tools
that we can do also in the short term
that are really useful for future future
meetings that you may have the other
thing I think is a low hanging fruit is
everything about location
the meeting buffering you know we've got
locations we know you're going to San
Francisco you know the the you're gonna
need a car maybe those to me is maybe a
step two you know the the reservations
and so on but the first one is the
buffers between meetings so we're
actually intelligent when you're
actually going to be clicking on except
for a meeting says hold on you may not
want to do that because you may need
some travel time for this and then it
actually gives you Suggestions by the
way we know Jonathan is going to be
freeing in an hour you'll have more time
you should probably pick that one so
there's a lot of intelligence that we
can bring through the location uh part
of it
um that's great and and also I mean
building the aggregator of information
to me is really really strong there's so
much we can do from that because you've
got all the sources of the calendar then
you've got you know if we start
aggregating the FourSquare check-ins we
start aggregating any information that
you want you want to put in your
calendar and we can start analyzing that
and so for us being this source of
aggregator of information no matter
where it's coming from and providing you
valuable information around that is huge
and that's around analytics but there's
a lot that goes behind capturing all
this data yeah okay data leads to
Insight right yeah yeah it does so yeah
analytics should be number one
absolutely
um and then prospective going forward
how you manage your time you know that
would be great yeah overall I think you
guys are really smart to do this because
there are other scheduling companies out
there and I think you said the checklist
is all about the same yeah this really
differentiates you and puts you in a
thought leadership position and then
just because you're a thought leader and
the Visionary you're going to get more
than your share of the business even
though features might be the same right
so it's it's great it's a good idea yeah
so we've got we've got a lot on our
plate and the the other the other
important facet to to also keep our mind
around is our own privacy
right and we're we're already pushing a
bit the envelope where where we're
saying to people
display on a page the times that you
want to make yourself available now
we're giving you the tools to really
manipulate that the way you are so
you're not exposing your calendar like
people are used to pre-busy calendar
it's like you're actually seeing times
that you're available so we've kind of
already flipped it and saying don't show
the times that you're busy show the
times that you want to meet people yeah
but but then we we then again push the
envelope a bit more where we said let's
create a directory with this and allow
people to join this directory and so
with that we got actually we're
surprised we think you know people would
opt out of this thing and are not opt in
we got 85 percent of our new users are
are joining our directory wow it's huge
so people are saying you know what I'm
comfortable enough with this information
that I'm going to publish it and also
not only publish it make it available
and indexable by Google search and so on
and so people are doing that and so
there's other things that now we're also
pushing the envelope where we're saying
there are some of your events that you
actually want to make public
and so yeah you've got the podcast and
all that but you know what you're in
your calendar you're gonna go at uh
Capital gross uh or the the thing Tech
crunch thing on Friday you want people
to know about it boom you can make it
public and also you can tweet it out to
people and so on so so that
functionality already exists today but
the point is we're also pushing the
envelope on privacy and so on and so the
challenge that we have as well is how do
we get Enterprises larger old school
financial institutions and so on to
start embracing this and so uh it's
really being embraced by the tech
companies like Google we have a shitload
of users from Google you know all the
tech companies are using our stuff how
do we get it to to the mainstream and so
I don't know if you have some thoughts
on that but you know because it's a
different framework right it's a yeah
yeah it is we often question is we're
out kind of talking to prospects whether
or not uh this is a generational divide
cultural divide I'll give you an example
as we go to talk to organizations
typically what we'll see is kind of a
bottom-up Groundswell right so you've
got middle management that have adopted
our product that are comfortable with
kind of the outward facing calendar come
and choose your time slots here's my
availability as you look top down more
senior Executives and c-suite they're
much more much less inclined to be
comfortable with that kind of thing
there's still more accustomed to privacy
even more accustomed to this kind of
Garden Wall environment
um and so it's partially our
responsibility to make them comfortable
with the technology to let them
understand that there's permissions
right and that they can open or close
the floodgates as much as they want but
it's something that we're dealing with
on an ongoing
certainly I know you guys have dealt
with your share of privacy issues I mean
is there a comment that you can make in
terms of your understanding of where
we're we are and
the way that the market is receiving
that
um well I think the pain point is high
enough that if the pain is high enough
that people will do anything to solve it
and privacy is the least of their
concerns when you know they're trying to
solve a pain point so
um
privacy is way over uh overdone as far
as I can tell I mean it's a nice topic
to talk about but the reality is
people generally don't care you know I
think you have a unique Viewpoint
because one of the things that we notice
is the community here is very insular
yeah right and so when you talk to the
valley folk the idea of privacy is kind
of kind of becomes ridiculous right we
need open transparent lives right uh
move back to kind of the Northeast and
you get a little bit of a different
flavor uh because you're by Coastal
you're you've got that perspective of
okay I understand what the Valley
Community looks like but I also
understand what white collar Boston
yeah well even me you know I'm big on
Facebook and Twitter and blogging and
photo sharing and all that stuff so
share share share Foursquare make is
creepy that one that's where I draw the
line why because uh there are very very
few people that I want to know where I
am all the time I don't mind on Twitter
if I say hey I'm at the Kenny Loggins
concert or hey I'm in I don't mind doing
that but I do mind uh because that's me
opting to do that that's giving
everybody ability to keep tabs right
when you do Foursquare then it's like oh
now I've got to remember who is
following me on Foursquare so when I do
this who's going to know that right
um where I am yeah so that one's a
little creepy and on Foursquare I only
accept people that that my inner circle
that I really really know I have
hundreds and hundreds of Foursquare
invitations that I just know yeah but
let's use Facebook as an example sorry
you've got a family and a human
um pictures of your family on Facebook
you've got some very personal things
um are you accepting business contacts
there absolutely you are so you're open
that way yeah so it's really the
question of where am I now